avant que la vidéo commence je profite
d'être dans le thème en vous proposant
une vidéo sur le jeu vidéo pour vous
annoncer l'arrivée d'un nouveau concours
in stand gaming pour participer c'est
très simple
accéder au lien dans la description et
entrez le nom du jeu que vous convoitez
et voilà bonne chance à tous bonjour à
tous j'espère que vous allez bien
écouter on parle de théorie de la pop
culture ici le dernier marvel le dernier
star wars un petit jeu vidéo par ci par
là bref mais comme tout passionné de
théories de pop culture
il existe des master class qui ont fait
que moi aussi j'ai eu envie d'imaginer
de belles théories et c'est un petit peu
le sujet du jour faire un petit
highlight sur les théories de la pop
culture et plus particulièrement du jeu
vidéo qui m'ont marqué et que je trouve
incroyable
évidemment je vais vous partagez des
théories qui moi mon plus
personnellement je compte sur vous pour
me partager des mystères que vous vous
trouvez vraiment incroyable où d'autres
théories sur le jeu vidéo qui vous ont
marqué peut-être même que ça fera
l'objet d'une autre vidéo à voir
bref comment sont sans tarder ça va nous
faire vraiment du bien je pense ce petit
retour dans le passé
[Musique]
je commence avec du très très très très
très fort sincèrement qui ne connaît pas
cette théorie c'est certainement à juste
titre la théorie la plus connue du jeu
vidéo mondialement la saga zelda
toujours été une mine d'or pour tout ce
qui touche aux mystères 35 années
d'existence plus de dix neuf jeux
officiels plus ou moins reliés entre eux
par une timeline défini il y a
clairement matière à s'amuser et parmi
toutes ces productions un jeu sort du
lot un jeu qui a marqué bon nombre de
joueurs considérés comme blizzard
dérangeant par moment voire fascinant
c'est majora's mask situé juste après
ocarina of time dans la timeline de
l'enfant c'est à dire le moment où link
a battu ganondorf transformer en ganon
et est renvoyé dans le passé pour
avertir zelda est le royaume des méfaits
de ce dernier l'histoire du genou contre
à ce qu'est devenu link après tout ça
une histoire qui sera beaucoup plus
personnel ce dernier a reposé la master
sword et son ami navy s'en est allé pour
toujours une séparation qui semble peser
sur le personnage puisque c'est un
élément qui servira pour l'intrigué de
base et son introduction
c'est en arrivant dans les bois perdus
que ce dernier bat clairement il va se
faire agresser racketter un je préfère
dire les termes perdant à la fois epona
sa jeune jument son ocarina et sa route
puisque link va tomber dans un énorme
trou qui sembleraient le mener dans un
monde alternatif monde alternatif où la
fin du monde semble se dessiner à cause
d'un certain skull kid équipé du masque
de majora en provoquant la chute de la
lune
link a donc trois jours pas plus pour
retrouver le masque et sauver la
situation
mais bon je ne vais pas m'attarder trop
longtemps sur l'histoire du jeu ce qui
nous intéresse avant tout c'est la
théorie
la théorie s'inspire invente ou des
travaux d'elisabeth kübler ross une
psychiatre qui a établi
une théorie alors non pas sur la saga
zelda mais sur ce que ressent une
personne ayant conscience que ses jours
sont comptés
on parle bien évidemment des cinq
fameuse étape du deuil traduit plus
précisément par le déni la colère le
marchandage la dépression et
l'acceptation une théorie qui colle
parfaitement à majora's mask et qui en
fait l'une des plus grandes théories du
jeu vidéo
la saga zelda nous a toujours habitués à
des contres et luxuriante une certaine
gaieté de l'epic un link qui reste
toujours droit même dans les pires
moments des justifications à autre
mesure et cetera
je pense par exemple au monde du
crépuscule de twilight princess qui me
faisait peur quand j'étais enfant et qui
me stressait mais qui dans la profondeur
n'est pas si différent du monde de la
lumière
ici rien ne va l'ambiance est glauque
lourdes les habitants sont celle où les
musiques sont parfois angoissantes link
se fait malmener et souffre même par
moment alors qu'il est le héros d'un jeu
pour enfants bref il ait une cohérence
de l'univers zelda qu'on ne retrouve pas
dans majora's mask et qui le rend très
unique
la théorie voudrait que link soit dans
la dernière ligne droite de sa vie que
ce dernier soit confronté à un terrible
destin et son périple finale dans le
monde 2 termina termine à terminer fin
bon on passe à la suite traduirait les
cinq étapes du deuil
la première étape symbolisée par le déni
serait exprimée par les habitants de
bourg clocher premier lieu emblématique
du jeu nous sommes confrontés à des
habitants qui prépare ce qu'ils
appellent le carnaval du temps et qui
n'ont que faire d'avoir une lune
menaçante prête à s'écraser au dessus de
leurs têtes ils mènent leur petite vie
comme si de rien n'était et cela leur
suffit comme si il n'y ait levitte
ans il n'y ait que leurs jours étaient
comptés et que la lune allez tous les
tuer seconde étape du deuil
la colère est deuxième lieu
chronologique du jeu le marais là bas
nous y retrouvons le palais mojo où le
roi est dans une très grande tourmente
suite à la disparition de sa fille la
princesse du peuple mojo aveuglé par la
colère du fait lit croit sa fille morte
il veut absolument punir quelqu'un
trouver justice se venger et c'est
malheureusement le singe de la princesse
qui va prendre
rassurez-vous le singe a survécu nous
passons maintenant aux piles des neiges
où nous retrouvons d'armani un célèbre
héros goron déchu qui a trépassé en
voulant combattre le démon du temple
étape du marchandage ce dernier en
voyant que link peut le voir grâce au
monocle de vérité et donc qu'il sait
utiliser la magie d'armani lui demande
de l'aider à revenir à la vie
une chose qui est impossible évidemment
ligne va finalement le libérer et calmer
ses souffrances
grâce au chant de l'apaisement prochaine
étape la grande baie avec le peuple aura
symbolisé par la dépression nous
retrouvons mikko grand guitariste d'un
groupe de musique qui est sur le point
de mourir
la chanteuse de son groupe le lui a
pondu des oeufs qui ont été volés et qui
ne seront jamais retrouvés
le guitariste mort et les yeux perdus
nous montrerons une chanteuse aura
muette envahi de tristesse
la voici l'étape de la dépression et
enfin certainement le lieu le plus
glauque de tous et la fin du voyage le
grand canyon dit cana et son château
symbolisant l'étape de l'acceptation un
lieu rempli mais remplis de morts
il n'y a que ça on y retrouve les
garrots des ennemis propre à majora's
mask qui sont des esprits d'anciens
guerrier ou assassin et qui ont pour but
de se tuer après un combat pour ne
révéler aucune information un lieu où la
mort est clairement décomplexée voir
qu'il épouse contrairement à tout ce
qu'on a connu auparavant
bien s besoin d'expliquer pourquoi cette
théorie est absolument folle la mort est
un point central de l'univers de
majora's mask et c'est un choix
audacieux quand on sait que le jeu est
destiné à de jeunes enfants
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui
peut paraître idiot dit comme ça mais si
nous rentrons dans le détail les cinq
étapes sont extrêmement bien symboliser
et surtout sont dans l'ordre
et oui le schéma colle parfaitement à la
théorie et cela on est même troublant
par moments notamment par rapport au
fait que le jeu se divise en cinq zones
principales comme les étapes du deuil
sans oublier de souligner que la
progression va crescendo on commence
avec des habitants joyeux mais dans le
déni puis un roi en colère a carrément
un fantôme qui ne veut pas accepter sa
mort pour passer à une personne qui
meurt devant nous et on termine sur un
lieu rempli de mort de plus si on
compare à ocarina of time
le seul et unique moment où la mort est
présente et plutôt décomplexée c'est via
igor le fossoyeur et encore c'est plutôt
amusant quand il est un fantôme
même dans le temple de l'ombre qui fait
normalement flipper un cela reste
surtout un aspect nous sommes face un
temple dont l'histoire est inconnu et
dont nintendo n'a jamais étalé les
détails alors que dans majora's mask
l'un des buts principaux du jeu et
d'accompagner les personnes en
souffrance vers un apaisement par
exemple nico moeurs clairement devant
nous et nous l'accompagnons à aller vers
l'au-delà séméga dérangeant puis là haut
dans l'univers zelda nous avons déjà eu
des réalités alternatives comme le monde
de l'eau rule
du crépuscule et bien il y a toujours
une explication une cohérence ses
univers alternatif font partie
intégrante de l'univers de zelda
il existe véritablement alors que
termine à rien on ne sait pas quel est
ce monde pourquoi il existe la seule
autre exception et le monde de phantom
hourglass
mais ce dernier reste dans la cohérence
la gaieté et la ligne d autres zelda et
comment parler de majora's mask sans
mentionner le masque de majora lui même
et le vendeur de masques du fait que le
masque est à l'origine des catastrophes
d'an termina et de la chute de la lune
c'est techniquement ce dernier qui
justifie la progression de link dans ces
cinq étapes
ce qui ferait du masque de majora la
mort en elle-même mais au vu du rôle du
vendeur de masques et par rapport au
fait que ce fameux masque lui appartient
il serait comme l'organisateur de toute
cette aventure morbide
ce dernier est celui qui va faire
débuter le voyage de link
celui qui va lui demander d'aller
chercher le masque
il est un personnage à part comparé à
tous les autres ce dernier disparaît
même à la fin du jeu il ne fait pas du
tout partie de termina et c'est lui qui
apparaît face à link lors des game over
avec sa mythique phrase usenet terrible
fight avec you tu es confronté un
terrible destin n'est ce pas bon
évidemment cette théorie est fausse
nintendo n'est pas du genre à promouvoir
la mort par le biais de ces jeux ni
promouvoir des ondes négatives et cetera
et effectivement la théorie a aussi ses
faiblesses déjà car cela voudrait dire
que link est mort à un moment du jeu
pour beaucoup c'est lors de sa chute à
cheval lors de l'introduction
mais je trouve que c'est un petit peu
incohérent car si link doit passer les
cinq étapes du deuil c'est qu'il doit
mourir et qu'il doit savoir qu'il doit
mourir et non qu'il soit mort dès le
début avant de passer les étapes donc la
mort de link serait plutôt situé à la
fin du show quand il quitte termina mais
encore une fois il y a un problème
puisque dans twilight princess le jeu
qui suit majora's mask avec une nouvelle
génération un nouveau héros une nouvelle
celle d'à eh bien nous avons la présence
de l'ombre du héros qui via sa forme de
l'eau va apprendre des techniques
ancestrales d'épéistes howling que de ce
jeu et ce dernier s'est approuvé par
nintendo via i roll historia est le
héros du temps celui d'ocarina of time
et majora's mask qui contrairement aux
personnes qui l'a sauvée dans majorat
n'a pas trouver l'apaisement il est un
héros oubliés car la réalité où ils à
sauver hyrule est tué ganondorf n'est
plus la sienne à cause du voyage dans le
temps donc en redevenant enfants aient
la juste dénoncer ganondorf qui sera
jugé et exécuté sauvant au passage des
centaines voire des milliers de
personnes mais laissant derrière lui la
gloire du héros et lui des ds mais bref
ce dernier est plutôt grand il possède
un savoir qu'il n'avait pas spécialement
dans ocarina of time ou encore majora's
mask
il semblerait que le ligne de ses jeux
est atteint sa taille adulte avant de
mourir d'ailleurs une certaine légende
dit qu'un enfant qui se perd dans les
bois perdus devient un skull kid alors
qu'un adulte devient quant à lui
installe fosse puis sans oublier le fait
qu'il appelle le héros du crépuscule
monfils traduisant dans tout cela une
descendance donc voilà mais il n'empêche
que la poésie derrière cette théorie du
deuil est incroyable et rajoute une
dimanche
l'histoire qui la rend encore plus
phénoménal et si c'était ça justement le
rôle d'une théorie dans la pop culture
s'amuser à embellir un univers pour
faire rêver les fans encore plus
longtemps que ce que propose le jeu à la
base de la même manière qu'un tableau
chacun aura sa perception sa vision de
ce que l'oeuvre souhaite transmettre
[Musique]
il est maintenant temps de parler de ma
théorie préféré sur ma saga de jeux
vidéo préférés et plus particulièrement
sur mon jeu préféré
enfin quoique c'est peut-être plus mon
jeu préféré maintenant mais quand même
tout d'abord une mise en contexte pour
que tout le monde puisse bien comprendre
l'univers et la théorie final fantasy 8
no conte l'histoire de school un
étudiant dans une école militaire pour
devenir incident
c'est lors de sa première mission
officielle en tant que sid soit un
soldat en quelque sorte qu'il fera la
rencontre de lino à
une jeune résistante qui cherche à
démanteler les actions de galles badia
une grande nation politique qui va
ériger une dictature militaire
il va s'avérer au final que galles badia
a été propulsée grâce aux actions d'une
sorcière et des as dans le lors d'un
final fantasy 8
il existe des sorcières et cela va être
un petit peu le coeur de lattes et aux
engrais au il existait un être ultime
doté de très grands pouvoirs quand ce
dernier aura été renversé par les hommes
habitent de sa puissance il transmettra
ses pouvoirs à des femmes qui de
génération en génération
à leur mort transmettront elle aussi ses
fameux pouvoir c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'héritage des sorcières et des as sera
finalement renversé par school et son
groupe et à sa défaite transmettra ses
pouvoirs à une autre jeune femme et
cellino à plat twist edéa était en fait
manipuler par une autre sorcière qui
semblent provenir du futur dont le nom
serait multimédia et qui souhaitent
compresser le temps pour tout faire
disparaître lino a maintenant devenu une
sorcière et le nouvel hôte d'ultimedia
tombera dans le coma avant de se
réveiller manipulé par la sorcière du
futur toujours en quête de mettre son
plan à exécution
je vous fais une ellipse scénaristique
pour vous épargner les détails
squall et son groupe laisseront ultime
essai à enclencher la compression
temporel afin de pouvoir la terrasse et
dans sa propre époque
chose qu'ils réussiront bien évidemment
bien maintenant la théorie je ne vais
pas vous mentir cette théorie est un pur
fantasme
il n'y a absolument rien qui
l'approuvent et il me semble même que
square enix
avait démenti pourtant elle résonne en
moi comme une master class linoa serait
donc ultime et sia la sorcière du futur
pourquoi tout d'abord lors du grand
final de final fantasy huit lits noah
est la dernière sorcière encore en vie
et active par le biais des péripéties du
jeu elle a reçu les pouvoirs d'aidé à la
sorcière de sa génération et chose qui
n'est pas spécialement précisé dans le
jeûne est sous-entendu c'est que les
sorcières sont des êtres ultime donc que
ce soit en terme de pouvoir de magie ou
encore de longévité
final fantasy 8 tourne autour d'une très
grande histoire d'amour et c'est la
thématique principale du jeu squall et
lino a sont faits l'un pour l'autre
sauf que si dans le symbole squall et le
chevalier servant de sa sorcière
traduisant un amour fou et bien la
réalité est que school est un simple
humain alors que lino a est une sorcière
donc cela sous-entend qu'à terme squall
devra mourir laissant linoa devenu un
être ultime seul est dans le chagrin de
perdre l'amour de sa vie ce qui
conduirait en gros à une certaine folie
une idée qui pourrait être propulsé par
la pseudo origine du nom ultime et sia
déjà il ya de très grandes chances
cultiver sia soit un pseudonyme étant la
sorcière la plus puissante jamais connu
capable de manipuler d'autres et
souhaitant lancer la compression
temporel le nom ultime et sia traduirait
le côté ultime avec pour suffixe le mot
mais si il y est donc à la libération et
donc tout ce côté divinité mais dans la
version japonaise son nom et harout
timis ia qui s'inspire du nom latin
artemisia soit du personnage historique
artémise de qui d'ailleurs est le nom du
team et sia dans les versions allemande
et italienne
artémise était la reine d'halicarnasse
et les pousses du roi mausolée en 351
avant jc lorsque le roi va mourir cette
dernière va ériger un mausolée
d'où le nom et 4 statue à son effigie
pour lui rendre hommage
un mausolée dont elle ira chaque jour
pour rendre mémoire à son amour perdu
et accessoirement boire les cendres de
son mari c'est une inspiration qui n'est
pas du tout banal et qui permet
clairement d'appuyer la théorie on
n'oublie pas également de mentionner que
la position du château d'ultimedia est
situé très proche du champ de fleurs à
côté de l'orphelinat lieu symbole de
l'amour de squall et lino à
où ils se sont promis de se retrouver
s'il venait à être séparés donc dans le
symbole si linoa est ultime et sia on
retrouve ce côté attentes de l'autre
sauf que ce col ne reviendra jamais
évidemment également la fameuse images
nous montrant la terrible ressemblance
entre linoa et ultime et sia évidemment
c'est très compliqué de juger cet
argument étant donné que nous sommes
face à un jeu de playstation première du
nom puis nous pouvons parler aussi de la
fameuse problématique de chronos grives
heures de son nom original le nom du
lionheart nom donné par ce col à sa
bague
c'est également le nom de la guardian
force d'ultimedia sauf qu élément
perturbant l'information de l'origine du
symbole du lion présent sur la bague de
ce pôle son collier ou encore sa gueule
blade est extrêmement personnel personne
n'en connaît l'origine à par lino à
quand school va lui prêter sa bague
avant le combat contre aider à
d'ailleurs quand le groupe finit par
vaincre la représentation de gréver ce
dernier laisse échapper des plumes
blanches éléments qui symbolise lino à
puis même tout simplement le château
d'ultimedia traduit à un certain vécu on
retrouve énormément de statut comme pour
l'inspiration de l'histoire d'artemis on
retrouve énormément de monstres
symbolique que seuls school et son
groupe dont linoa faisait partie ont
combattu durant leur périple dans final
fantasy 8
bref il existe moult détails et
interprétations qui vont dans le sens de
la théorie et pour aller encore plus
loin dans le fantasme il faut se pencher
plus en détail sur ultime et sia dont la
majorité des final fantasy nous
connaissons le boss final très tôt dans
le jeu un procédé qui va nous permettre
de voir l'évolution de l'antagoniste et
de comprendre ses intentions
sa psychologie comme par exemple kafka
dans final fantasy 6 ou même exdeath
dans final fantasy 5 ou bien parce que
le personnage en question est lié aux
protagonistes principaux
comme nous avons l'exemple avec cefir
hausse par rapport à cloud ou bien final
fantasy 10 entre ject et titus
ici nous n'avons rien ils ont voulu
innover et casser les codes avec final
fantasy 8 et cela nous a donné
ultime et sia un boss final avec une
histoire inconnue un background
inexistant et qui sert juste d'entités
malsaine que le joueur doit battre pour
terminer le jeu et c'est une
problématique intéressante car du coup
cela amène clairement les fans à
fantasmer sur l'histoire du personnage
et imaginer son background même par
rapport à ses intentions tout est flou
nous savons culte immédiat veut lancer
la compression temporelle pour devenir
le seul être existants et omnipotent de
l'univers
mais pourquoi cela cette dernière a eu
la connaissance qu'un side légendaire
viendrait mettre un terme à son
existence
il s'agit bien évidemment de squall sauf
qu'au final toutes les actions
d'ultimedia l'amèneront à sa défaite
un paradoxe de prédestination si elle
était resté bien sagement dans son
époque sa défaite ne serait jamais
arrivé et nous avons aussi la présence
d'un paradoxe de buddh strap puisqu'à la
fin du combat final ultime et cias pôles
seront renvoyés dans le passé pour que
cette dernière puisse transmettre ses
pouvoirs de sorcières avant de s'en
aller
sauf qu'en faisant ça squall fera naître
l'idée de la création du cid soit les
soldats destiné à combattre les
sorcières à aider à
chose qu'elle mettra en place avec son
mari et du coup ce cours elle deviendra
incident quand il sera plus grand
sid qui sont ceux qui vont mettre un
terme au règne de terreur du team et sia
est ce que vous comprenez le paradoxe
bref tout ça pour vous dire que nous ne
savons rien sur ultime et sia est donc
belle imagination a totalement sa place
ici mais au final est ce que tout cela
est si important cela fait 20 ans que la
théorie existe et que le débat n'a
jamais été clos la théorie à ses
faiblesses bien évidemment tout n'est
basée que sur de l'interprétation et des
tout petits détails
final fantasy 8 est un jeu un parfait
avec des moments de flou dans son
scénario ou même son univers mais c'est
ça qui fait son charme en fait et
aujourd'hui 22 ans après est ce que l'on
peut considérer que l'oeuvre appartient
toujours à square enix dans le sens où
le jeu a fait ses ventes a vécu n'a
maintenant plus de news le concernant
seuls ceux qui vont
vivre l'expérience et la partager sont
aujourd'hui les seuls à faire vivre le
jeu alors si la théorie de lino a devenu
ultime et sia permet de raviver la
flamme de ff8 encore vingt ans après
c'est qu'elle a le mérite d'exister et
même si square enix décide de la
démanteler pour ne pas dénaturer
l'oeuvre d'origine
je trouve personnellement qu'elle
apporte une nouvelle lecture qui me
donne envie de me replonger dans son
univers et même de rejouer au jeu alors
que je les fais il ya déjà des années et
ce sont toutes ces problématiques qui
ont fait que j'ai eu envie de vous
parler de théorie sur youtube permettre
de rendre hommage à des oeuvres qui ne
sont plus que des souvenirs pour
certains
bref essayer d'étendre un univers et
prolonger leur histoire
quand je vous dis que le 'lion' rares
soit avec vous des fois je me dis que
c'est un petit peu dépassé
cela reflète un simple tripes que
j'avais à l'époque de quand je faisais
que des vidéos final fantasy sur la
chaîne mais en même temps cela me
rappelle les tout débuts de caen je vous
proposais mais toute première théorie
car c'est grâce à des théories comme
celle de la mort de ligne dans majora's
mask ou plus particulièrement celle de
ynwa devenu ultime et sia que je vous
parle de théories sur la chaîne youtube
car ces dernières m'ont fait rêver et
mon replonger dans des univers dont
j'avais totalement tourné la page et
c'est pourquoi pour moi ce sont les
meilleurs théorie du jeu vidéo
alors écoutez que le lionheart soit avec
vous à vous maintenant de me partager
les théories de jeux vidéo qui vous ont
fait rêver je suis sûr qu'il y en a au
moins une
et sinon bah n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à la chaîne a laissé un petit
pouce bleu puis à me suivre sur les
réseaux j'espère vraiment que cette
vidéo vous aura plu j'ai voulu tenter
quelque chose d'un petit peu différent
tout en restant dans la théorie donc
voilà et puis ici l'expérience vous
plaît pourquoi pas recommencer avec de
nouvelles thématiques avec d'autres
théories c'est à vous de me dire allez
c'était argot rock
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]